yeah yeah yeah better be wearing a laugh
you better be wearing a lab coat
shut up
because you're talking about glycogen
and that's why
you know what dude yo you're a piece of
[ __ ]
i had a great time oh my god dude look
man i mean yeah i've been in the same
room together in a minute the whole
thing about years the whole thing about
this career and the whole thing about
this life is that if you don't have
people to share it with and if you don't
build friendships and you don't have
and when that all gets taken shattered
away and part of it what happens is with
success
and with getting older and kids you you
there becomes this diaspora it becomes
like this it just atomizes
yeah nobody hangs out and if you think
about the times that you [ __ ] with
what are your memories your memories
might be accomplishments but i think
most of our memories are the times we
were laughing yeah when i think about
the like think about it like what what
do you connect to to a place
to a time
it was the amount of laughter even when
it was hard like you're trying you're
practicing at something but like
it's usually just i don't know
the energy you feel like the energy was
there though oh we just skipped a beat
yeah you didn't skip that that's why i'm
glad you kind of like showed up five
minutes before because i i was hoping he
would come early because then you know
the chemistry on camera yeah yeah i mean
it was just yeah exactly he's so [ __ ]
funny no oh
yeah yeah i know it's super boring thank
you
thumbs up because uh world record
theo can just like say man you sound
like you sound like a guy in a castle
behind a curtain right yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i do at that point you know
but it makes sense yeah yeah two months
did you have a good weekend i saw i saw
the halloween uh family get up start
star star wars family i didn't have any
saying that my girl just like well we
all need to be like the same so yeah
she's a star wars it was fantastic dude
boston is baby yoda dude oh
he shut the street down
yes people couldn't get enough of them
they're so cute so [ __ ] cute so cute
so cute i was surprised like uh jay
called me because you know they're an
hour ahead right democracy or yeah yeah
and jay's like i've never seen more kids
trick or treating he's like it's mayhem
because i ran off candy in 30 minutes
wow oh damn because they missed last
year i think they're just candy crush
well and then i told jay i go man i
wonder if it's gonna be like that nellie
cause it's different here compared to
other cities oh it's different dude's
packed except for there are certain
neighborhoods with some of the wealthier
neighborhoods like in telugu lake and
stuff some of the houses
had
large signs saying due to covet we're
not trick-or-treating and there was one
house that had police tape around it
well no they didn't have no kids suck a
zombie apocalypse
yeah yeah go [ __ ] yourself uh yeah
they're probably older who knows
i teach
there's another celebrity that had a big
celebrity who had someone handing like
hired someone a hand candy out well with
a table far away from their house
[ __ ] off i didn't see any of that i mean
where i'm at everything's completely
unpacked
so many kids on this it's so fun i feel
like it's when everybody comes together
yeah you have you have people from all
different socioeconomic backgrounds
knocking on doors and it's just a happy
time
yeah unity thing you're watching your
kids collect [ __ ] my daughter at 13 she
goes off with her cool friends and they
dress up
by the way my daughter hit me with this
she's dressed up as a man
from one of her fantasy novels he's like
this
a wig and everything and i go and i go
i'm joking around i go
oh cool are you
trans
that didn't go over well she goes thanks
for the microaggressions oh no and i
went
don't talk about microaggressions
yeah don't talk about that so we had a
little we had a little mix up with that
yeah
that's fun yeah but you know what she
hit me with and i think you'd appreciate
this
i said something about twitter she goes
dad nobody in my generation takes
twitter seriously
oh i win what she goes it's not a real
place and it's nothing but negative
toxic [ __ ]
i went she's 13. and i go all your
friends feel away she goes yeah and they
try to cancel one of our characters one
of these fantasy characters who i guess
was politically incorrect twitter tried
to can't oh yeah tried to cancel the
character and all of us were like um not
even a real character and shut up yeah
it was unbelievable dude i was like
there's some light at the end of this
time i guess young kids are on time
makes that makes a lot of sense yeah but
but but it's not they try to keep it
like they try to keep it from being a
body shaming place and stuff like when
when people get on somebody for being
fat there's a whole group of people and
they're like hey hey you know yeah
that's nice because they're aware i mean
so so kids my daughter's age are
actually aware how negative it is yes
and they're aware of what it's doing to
them that's very very true i did when i
did a show for kids one of the comics
before me was like so what you guys want
like woke stuff and they were like no
that's not what they all did they all
straight up it was like
13 or like 16 year olds yeah man but
they were like no we don't want that no
they want common sense yeah they all get
to get along together in fact i was
talking about all this woke stuff and
i'm worried and this kid is 19 goes man
you guys sound old
because they're in it they're not yeah
no it's old things i'm over here looking
at it reading the headlines that makes a
lot of sense yeah they're not reading
like cnn and ms meeting
however however i will say this i was
talking to a very big director who has
to cast a very big movie
and uh
the diversity clauses in it are so
beyond what you can imagine so you're
not getting the best actors oh well no
saying it's not even that when you write
a character okay so say you want to put
a handicapped character in there
there are they will tell you
when you're writing it that the the
handicap character can have no flaws and
cannot be sympathetic
here's the problem with that
the problem with that is that when you
write a character any interesting
character has to be flawed has to have
like weaknesses and because it's called
a human being yeah they have to have
contradictions yeah so you can't be like
i'm in a wheelchair and i'm amazing it's
amazing no it's not it sucks yeah and
it's a struggle and we all know it yeah
self in there but these [ __ ] these
these people who don't write these
people who are listening to the horde to
these because they get these special
interest groups that get together and
they go we're tired of having otherly
abled people be portrayed this way and
they put a lot of pressure the problem
with listening to that and telling the
artist the writers that is that you're
gonna get [ __ ] product you're just not
going to get a good product and then so
for example when ted lasso came out yeah
the whole talk among all the executives
was
people want a light positive energy
thing so that's what we need now guys
that's what our metrics are saying okay
then along came a show called squid game
and the darkest [ __ ] in the world and
everybody watched it and it's like
we're wrong well no [ __ ] it's called
those executives don't they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing they live in
a rich bubble they don't know what's
real yeah but you also can't look at
data no you can't look at this like you
know this creativity doesn't come with
data no
jesus christ it's really interesting
okay i started uh you season three oh
how'd you like it i just finished it's
all right really it's not as good as the
other two seasons what episode are you
on four four hard to keep [ __ ] going
yeah i think three students tough and
sometimes they're married now they have
a kid
so that's when they're all around
sitting around going how can we keep
this going because we you know it's
still well done but it's just not like
the other two
i really like season three because
they're focusing on uh how crazy love is
see i don't like that you don't like it
no they're both serial
get out killers here come on they're not
happy
i'm saying they happen to get married oh
they have you know what i'm saying it's
like they're both killers get out of
here i don't know i watched the
storyline watch the other two do you
know that show on hbo the other two it's
based on justin bieber's real life so
justin bieber has uh i think he had a
brother who's an actor and a sister
who's a dancer and it didn't work out
for them and they're older
i think i think bieber has like a
younger sister but she's like a child
okay well i i just this is about uh
bieber uh somebody this is about justin
bieber no i think it says they roasted
justin bieber yeah this is a kid who's
like justin bieber but he's he's got a
he's got it he's just a brother he's
like young kid yeah
he's killing it and his older brother
and sister
it all it just misses
it's a little sketchy it it it people
were saying it was good it just kind of
misses it so i'm sorry live head writers
chris kelly and sarah schneider yeah
it's a little too sketchy and that's
their mistake they should just not you
shouldn't be able to smell a joke and
that's all i can do but molly shannon is
one of my favorites she's in it oh she's
in it
i watched that uh brittany murph murphy
doc oh yeah what was it on uh it's on
hbo what's so crazy
it's
i don't know like people make it seem
like there's like some conspiracy around
her
death
yeah like it just came out and then she
was with just a shitty dude that was
like very controlling which was i think
banging her mom i know yeah it was like
it's like a weird yeah because when when
brittany murphy died they stayed when he
was they stayed together and she would
sleep she would sleep in the bed
with um brittany yeah they would sleep
in the bed together
but it's just i don't know i don't know
it just seems like uh i don't think so
it just seems like a typical hollywood
kind of i don't know and then they said
they died from the mold in the house
but there was a the the lady that did
their autopsy
um yeah she said there was no mold
because she said it it comes like when
when someone dyes a mold or something
like that you could see it in their
lungs
and they didn't see mold in the lungs
didn't you have a drug over this no
that's not all that's right
do you think that's normal it's weird no
i mean i don't think it'd be like
what else what else can who dies
pneumonia
back-to-back
also they that guy had
she also had anemia she would she wasn't
healthy but neither was that guy i mean
if you look at him he want healthy
either no of multiple drock and drug
intoxication yeah they had they had a
yeah they found a lot of blood well so
if you're not eating and you have no
iron in your body you're taking a lot of
drugs your heart can stop that's what i
that's yeah see see that see multiple
drug intoxication i might do it i might
do it and then what'd the boyfriend die
from chin
but i think he said i think it said the
boyfriend or the husband died at the
same time he was in the exact same time
he was he was very like it was it was
weird he was a drug guy
and he pulled all that maybe it's just
uh yeah have enough iron he died on
pneumonia
simon
what did he do simon
he was he tried to do something i don't
know if he was like a writer he lie so
he lied he told everybody that he was
like a writer he was a famous director
and all these yeah other countries but
then once people start to like look into
wayne like really like look like hey who
is this guy really they found like that
the guy was wanted in other countries
the guy was like a criminal he was just
like really sketchy so no one really
knows what he was like very manipulative
and i guess at the time brittany murphy
wasn't like
like her confidence had went down
because
hollywood said something crazy to her oh
they said you're you're lovable you're
not [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] her up right there when
when you kind of ate her up you're
lovable and not [ __ ] oh and then
like dude howard stern was uh when she
was dating ashton kutcher howard stern
was like yeah you're dating the the fat
ugly girl from clueless and asha kutcher
was like no she's not the fat ugly girl
she's a beautiful girl dude even hey
howard stern's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
hey you're a [ __ ] guy also for him to
call him buddy ugly god
what a shitty thing to do to a young
girl too you don't think that's going to
[ __ ] her up yeah and so
and she talked about in an interview how
she read like she would read all those
which is like i can't understand that
she's almost like reading comments yeah
you know in the comment section
especially
yeah but she would read all those
headlines about her and oh dude the one
that went hard on her was uh
perez hilton yeah he went super hard on
her now
he feels bad he's kind of dialed back
right yeah like because he thinks about
he thinks about all that
i think yeah
he's in that docking he kind of like
owns up to like that about it yeah he
went too bad yeah
he wrote a thing like saying like she's
the next one to die yeah
she's the next one to die yeah he better
party she didn't look healthy so he's
like i bet you she's the next one it's
like jesus that's your business yeah
yeah that's just awful
there's no longevity but i think how you
doing howard stern i remember you know
when i stopped listening to howard stern
he was talking to someone we went to
sears girl some woman and a nicole smith
no he was just talking to some gal and
she and he goes well this is the the
main thing was he i remember he said are
you fat it was anna nicole smith and she
said yeah
and he said well that's kind of gross
something like that and then and then
the real thing that really [ __ ]
killed me
when i watched him he had this contest
he and his [ __ ] loser friends had a
contest
for women who were ugly who where you
put a paper bag over their head like
they have amazing bodies then you take
their face off they bag off and
everybody goes ah like that oh that's
what he had these women these
self-esteem that was his thing that's
what and i was like oh you're a piece of
[ __ ] like you do that to people who are
already feeling terrible about
themselves you're a piece like i just
hate that now he's going to therapy like
going station castle and judges
talk [ __ ] to everybody he's just he i
remember seeing that i go well who the
[ __ ] thinks that's good i think that
just sucks man oh [ __ ] it just makes the
world i don't know i don't know he went
that hard oh yeah dude used to be vile
uh yeah i just heard the thing about
brittany murphy and then the thing he
um
when he was talking to anna and nicole
smith and like he was just kind of like
yeah you know he did that he did that
wasn't those weren't like because i
would watch his interviews with like
musicians and like it was just kind of
regular he's supposed to be a really
good interviewer yeah that's what that's
what's up without no one else but if i'm
dating a girl and you say that about her
like say say you're dating a girl and
and i'm ashlyn kushner and you say she's
the fat ugly girl from clueless i'm
surprised they put up with like you know
it's almost like i feel like in that
instance i'm not trying to be macho i
believe it's appropriate to get up and
punch him in the [ __ ] face i believe
in that situation you should get up and
just i don't know do something to him
that makes it but it's also it's not
like he's brad pitt
he looks like [ __ ] he sucks he's always
apparently he's got a dick like the size
of michael yeah that's why he's like
that's why he has so much aggression
yeah but don't be so nasty to people
like what a sh it's what got him on the
map you know the original troll yeah i
don't know that's where yeah i didn't
know he was like because i watch all his
interviews with like musicians
they're kind of like pretty cool like i
mean
i don't know it's one thing to be honest
and call it like it's like always fine
about the sex life of celebrities and
[ __ ] like you oh good i mean one of the
best interviews of all time yeah he's a
dick man i i know another guy whose wife
committed suicide and he was a he was a
dj
and he was harassing him
because his wife had died
he used to do is when when he was on
serious before when he was just a radio
jockey he would he want to be the
biggest in the market he would come into
that market like our boy in cleveland
and just bully them until they got out
and then he took over yeah yeah he had
people call him
super beast yeah i i don't
that's a guy you know yeah all right
guy made his money evil knievel you know
you ever see anything on evil knievel
even a guy wrote a bad article on him
and evil knievel waited for the guy with
a baseball bat broke his [ __ ] babies
and went to jail he goes well i don't
take i don't deal with that
it's like you know hey howard sometimes
here maybe you need to get your [ __ ]
nose flattened do you
student loans um are a [ __ ]
okay student debt is a very real thing
for a lot of people dude and i want to
pay them off all right i want to pay
them off
then you got to get earnest because you
can save thousands potentially with
refinancing federal student loan
payments are on hold but with rates this
low now is a good time to refinance dude
you tell me earnest loans has some of
the lowest rates flexible payments and
in-house team ready to help me out yeah
what refinancing you can reduce your
loan terms save money combine multiple
loans into one simple monthly payment if
you have questions talk to real human at
earnings for help all right with earnest
it takes only two minutes to see what
your new rate could be and there's no
credit impact and right now ernest is
offering the fire and kid listeners and
viewers a hundred dollars cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com fighter not available in all
states though
once again you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com fighter
to refinance your student loan visit
earnest.com fighter for more details not
available in all states terms and
conditions apply earnest loan student
loan refinancing made by earnest
operations llc and mls number 120 4917
california financing law license number
605-4788-535 mission street san
francisco california 94105 visit
earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses
let's take a little break from the
shenanigan with the boys because ufc 268
is here we're doing a live calabash
fight companion for the main card 7 p.m
pacific only on thick boy youtube but if
you're gonna watch it bet some bank dude
with draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc and
man they have quite the offer for you
this weekend all right they have a
special odds boost for all the final kid
listeners and viewers the fighters this
week my picks are michael chandler rose
and kamar usman that's right that's
right you got two favorites well rose is
even money chandler's the dog camaro is
a big heavy favorite but guess what all
you do is head to the app right now find
the brennan shop picks under the odds
boost tab doesn't matter if you're a new
or existing customer bet on it get your
boosted odds right along with me it's
parley all three have to win in order
for all of us to win all right again
it's chandler rose kamar osman they all
three win we're making bank they're
boosting your odds at draftkings all new
users can
download the top raid draftking
sportsbook app now use the promo code
fighter when you sign up bet on my
parlay the bren shop parlay of fighters
to win saturday night for ufc 268 take
advantage of my special odds boost
that's promo code fighter only a
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the ufc must be 21 or
older new jersey pennsylvania indiana
michigan virginia only restrictions
apply see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details gambling problem call 1-800
gambler or in virginia 888-532-3500
i guess he's turned now i guess he's
either well you mean now you've made 600
million dollars [ __ ] off and didn't pay
any of his employees is that true no
like high pitcher those guys they're
they're broke
beetlejuice all of them amazing that's
what that's the one guy who was his main
guy forever is suing him he's like hold
on dude use my name like everything i
get nothing
none of it surprises me yes
yeah not good [ __ ] off i've actually
enjoyed this show for a long time but
yeah i mean yeah i mean it's interesting
the interviews i watched but you just
listen to music yeah no
did you what did you do for halloween
did you do you celebrate halloween did
you dress up i went to a con no i don't
[ __ ] dress up did you dress up i did
not no yeah i went to a concert what's
that i went to a concert went to a metal
show suicide silence how was it it was
good at the belasco they opened for a
band called ginger
out of the ukraine are they redheaded
no no the gingers that'd be fun but it's
no one has right here yeah that's one of
the clips i took yeah
so the guitar player of this man chris
garza is a big fan of you he loves you
he he saw us in brea
oh was it the one guy who was like i'm
in a band yeah yeah i went oh good for
you man yeah yeah i didn't know what
that it was
keep pushing hopefully you get there
i used your marketing for my band
yeah like yeah like i was like that's
good he looks at like you're you know
like he idolizes he was great likes to
fall he's great but yeah he uh he even
wore a thick boy shirt on stage oh [ __ ]
he wore that and he didn't get a picture
of that he did it's on his instagram
that's like that's like i'm
[Music]
yeah they're actually insane i love the
diversity in there
that's like that's like the time i was
in london and i'm hanging out with this
girl this girl we get in this mercedes
chauffeur and i go oh cool what's his
name chris garza little dowdy girl there
and i go and i go what do you do she
goes i'm in a band and i go okay and i
say to my friend i would banish again
she goes spice girls that's him with you
right there yeah he's great yeah
there you go
uh go to his
hold on go up
damn he's rock go to the left rocking
hard
the video oh it's a video on there man i
thought he had to pick oh it's in his
story
yeah he's a really nice dude
[Music]
was a belasco theater nice
so they have a big they have a pretty
big following yeah yeah very massive
following yeah it was it was fun man my
dumb ass let's get hang in there yeah
let me know they're just touring around
yeah okay see you later dude
we sell more tickets than you
all right sorry man sorry all right
you're playing in arena hey kid you know
keep your chin up dude it didn't get
easier get it you got it okay see you
later dude
but i told him he was talking about
metal banding oh chappelle's out there
go talk to chappelle about it yeah yeah
yeah yeah we started we talked for a
while yeah yeah he was a good dude yeah
he's good do you like stand up or or
sing anymore do i like stand up or sing
anymore stand up
yeah but like if you could write into
any band you want or be like a major
headline comic what would you do major
headlining comic instead of being like
yeah instead of being a bad guy yeah
because there's something dope it would
be pretty dope but there's just
something about uh comedy that just like
it's just all on you you know what i
mean like you don't have to like you
can't rely on anyone i like that i like
that like kind of challenge it's the
best yeah oh it's the best job it's the
best and you have to deal with all the
dynamics like you hear bands all the
time hate each other yeah exactly like i
did a laugh factory long beach last
night
25 people
but you know what makes sense i had a
[ __ ] blast yeah it was just fun like
it was just like the in
even it was even though it was only 25
people in that room like but still like
it's just still a good time just going
up there like you i don't know and just
doing that
through to a crowd of twenty five i
don't know if you're on like corn or
some [ __ ] like that i mean if i was in
coins
the problem
oh you know what's up yeah but here's
the problem
radio head all these things all these
places your
radio um radiohead yeah you had it you
had it right the problem with these vans
is that even if you're really big they
were talking i think it was radio
talking about this they're like
you're on the road for a year a year
long and you're you're you're taking
buses and planes and what happens is
you've been singing the same song now
with stand-up you can change it up
no that kind of no but you're because it
began but more importantly you're
available at each other 24 7. 24 7. and
after a while they wouldn't look at
these i don't want to be around anybody
no dude they wouldn't look at each other
they'd be sitting in the bus they
sitting and they're they just they would
not look at each other because they said
aerospace and metallica they didn't talk
yeah you gotta show up at the concert
like i think they they each have their
own tour bus they have their own tour
bus and then they only get together in
the back room they go over their set and
they hit the stage you kind of need it
they need that you kind of know after a
while you go crazy because they don't
tour the way that we do like we we just
do like we're home they're every day and
then thursday we leave thursday back on
sunday granted as soon as we get off
those damn flights we're like
they do it sometimes they'll literally
go from city to city yeah and like
it's crazy i thought what taylor swift
said she's three hundred dollars the
most touring dates ever 365. like she
just spent her life it would go from
tokyo to [ __ ] yeah i think it was
close to two years she was on the road
for her really yeah for one of her more
so much money michael jackson michael
jackson talked about how he would get
annoyed of touring he goes it's he goes
because like especially yeah
oh my god that shows seven thousands
mick jagger talked about that yeah
it's like it's like and springsteen said
that yeah
yeah anything i want
cause i go what do you do for a workout
and he goes i can eat when i'm touring i
can do whatever i want i could eat all
the pizza in the world you you just when
you're playing for four hours a night
[ __ ] he's burning down
singing and jumping around that would be
tough yeah think about moonwalking every
night in the same playlist over and over
oh my god
you can't come out with anything new
like yeah oh how about this how about
this every time he plays so springsteen
would play something new
and and literally
you'd see everybody going to the
concession like you'd see it'd be it was
like ants you just the minute he started
a new song it's a new song
and he and i said i kind of was like it
was a little touchy i said yeah does it
is it tough to and he goes yeah i mean i
see them all walking out
that's bruce springsteen certain artists
though they've gotten to a point to
where like
you got to do what those fans want to do
well i heard lynn bishop give him the
hits i heard limp bizkit came out with
an album and it sounds pretty good i
heard one song off it but yeah from that
one song the sober biscuit
he's still right because he's sober now
yeah i think so yeah i think i'm not
sure he is yeah i did a golf charity
thing with him he's sober there oh i
assume he's still sober yeah how's this
golf
about as good as mine okay not good
he looked the part though yeah
they've been doing hard for years oh
yeah
it's a good album i hear it's good yeah
i mean
we have my boy listening to the whole
thing today he said pretty good pretty
good god how about that writer limb
biscuit still sucks no that's their
opinion
i thought the same thing too i was like
take it easy
let me see you put out a [ __ ] is that
what they said there was that's that's
carson daily trending oh it's called
still well he was big with them on mtv
right oh god oh so it's probably just
i remember carson's got it he made that
new york yankees red hat so [ __ ]
poppin
what
i don't see anything oh you're just
reading some eminem stuff
good for them still doing it yeah
yeah they did a lot of palooza this year
and
people were like that was the best
performance of it really that's a lot of
weight he's so fat right wow yeah i
think i think he might be vegan too i
ran into him at a
what are we running to him at crossroads
well that annoys me but yeah that's cool
at least whatever gets them right
yeah god he was so [ __ ] fast back in
the day
on [ __ ] uh oddly enough he got he got
a lot of hate too
yeah
he was his band was like the band like
that was like
people just hated love to hate on love
to hate on i feel like nickelback took
the crown now right nickelback has that
that's karma electra
yeah she's painful she's i worked with
her she's a great we did we had a fight
scene so much fun yeah she's a just a
[ __ ] great gal yeah she's ridiculous
yeah she she used to date dave navarro
dennis rodman but like if you see her
like if you see her not dolled up it's
interesting she's still banging
she's it's you know
you you
she's very pretty but she's super pretty
mm-hmm but she doesn't dress the part
like she uses either like her were you
uh her or pamela anderson you know what
i'm saying yeah i was excited yeah yeah
who'd you pick her all day
you could you go pamela anderson i work
with both of them all right take it easy
you keep saying that i know i can change
my mind spend a lot of time i don't care
look at me i see them i love him hey
look at me back in bay watch days do you
understand me nah i understand i love
her
i love her but
you you'd go she's gorgeous she's so
gorgeous she's also cool she's also like
i don't know her eyes are crazy yeah
she's beautiful
that's her harley quinn
she's also featured in good burger
dancing
i worked with her 20 years ago and she
looks every bit as good jesus why she
got a picture of me on there
who let me he passed away motorhead yeah
damn you know your [ __ ] yeah i mean
that's a pretty big deal dude
yeah she's fantastic great eyes
yeah crazy eyes that's what she's
wearing oh that's cool that's impressive
mtv awards wait was she was she a scary
movie yep uh no she was in yeah scary
movie it's the
parody the parody one right yeah yeah
and he's like trying to kill him she
won't die yeah
they stab her in the chest and her
silicone breast comes out
so funny
she's so good
i love those movies
i heard from pamela anderson in a hot
minute just chilling i know she got her
citizenship
out here she got married recently i mean
citizenship because she's from canada
she got it
she's canadian yeah
older pictures
hey
i mean yeah she was discovered i think
on a jumbotron right wait what they
showed her at like a cfl game everyone
was like who the [ __ ] is that like so
just someone the video is like hey i
think you could do some stuff that's
amazing
yeah yeah the shoes got
i mean you shouldn't seen your dance she
just she's just just unbelievable
possibly hot when she was young it was
[ __ ] stupid yeah didn't she have a tv
show
that was like no no yes she did no i'm
not saying that's not the billboard oh
no she had her own show
where they were like kind of like
secret agents or something
i don't know that sounds like well you
go yes she does i know she's gonna bug
me yes
i mean ridiculous
yeah she made some rich guy think
recently
now she's probably just chilling
she was never with billy bob thornton
right i don't think so probably she's
with homeboy no that billy bob was with
uh
dancers
she's a woman there she's getting older
that's her that's not her yes it is i
think it is just a bad angle no that is
not her that is her that's an older
woman now
still pretty that's pam anderson very
pretty it's probably 50 at least unless
you might be my age
yeah yeah really i'm going to stick with
carmen electro i'm not on this side
now you keep saying you went from 30
years ago i'm gonna
double down on caramel lecture though
all right
all right buddy
do you what did you do for halloween cat
did you have a only fancy party or some
[ __ ] on friday i went to a party in uh
downtown it was interesting it was the
first time i've ever been to a club uh
stevie and i nightclub kind of they had
turned like an old bank into a nightclub
they had an open bar it was cool steve
and i stayed there for an hour people
watched and then went to laurel hardware
to go eat
it was fun but it was a lot of like
young
influencers and people who wanted to be
around influencers i just didn't feel
very comfortable yeah it felt kind of
networky yeah there was a dj who had
like um a mask like a big like bobble
head mask on and then she took her top
off and was djing the whole set that's
cool that was cool like a marshmallow
with big tits yes exactly it's like
marshmallow with big tits and then
at first stephen i didn't think she was
going to actually take her top off and
then she did it's just like
big shiny plastic tits fantastic it's
great it was great amazing body and she
just did her entire set tonight titties
out yeah with her titties i guess that's
her thing on her head yeah with the
thing on her head so you don't know what
she is i approve
i know yeah sounds like a fantastic
party they had food too like you know
around with their orders just open
so they don't eat you know yeah a lot of
people are on drugs and nobody cares
about them i don't know everyone was
vaping what did you dress up as cat uh i
was a cop because my squid game costume
did not come in oh i ordered it so uh
early in the month of october but then i
guess the
merchant who sold on amazon is from
china and they just didn't have it in
time so they said it would come in by
november 4th thanks for nothing i guess
you could still it's like a jumpsuit you
just wear true it'll be cool just walk
around i don't know if i'm gonna do that
though who i would you would did you do
anything jen i like fishing
with little brows do you wear a mask
no not masking we went to the marina del
rey and it is
disgusting in there
there was just like we literally saw a
condom floating by
trash bags there's like homemade [ __ ]
[ __ ] waters i got two fish i have it
on my instagram i got two fish filled
with you don't want to come
i took one back i'm gonna eat it you two
went back and ate it i'm gonna eat it
disgusting
how big is it you got a picture you
don't need this did they say picture
yeah i wouldn't eat that raw dude you
need a venice [ __ ] what kind of fish is
it no i froze it though that's the thing
so if i froze it i feel like you're
i don't know bro that's where a lot of
seals are you see any seals uh no honey
a lot of great watts a lot of great
watts right there
we've already been out here for how long
taylor white pointless look at giant
bastard right there that's where you're
going
giant bath what the hell are you gonna
make one [ __ ] i would use
popper right
this is the one i kept that's an opal
eye there's no size limit and they're
usually around this size but mile's
pretty decent size oh where is it
what'd you use to bait that thing in
just regular frozen shrimp what'd you
use to paint it in yeah you like that
yeah use
some worms use a real worm wear them up
a little bit little two but that's not
that's like a god
hey that's a baby fish throw it back in
right now it's not a baby i'm gonna get
home and then use it for something just
started oh my god
those are all grown yeah
wants to go back to its [ __ ] clan
did little browser taylor catch anything
yeah any catching that's hard to catch
fish hard to catch fish
yeah it's very difficult have you gone
with david lucas yet he's he's been he
fishes all the time yeah kidding i
didn't know what his profile never
thought he was a fisherman
he doesn't eat them we don't know randy
though you know
what a weird thing i don't know
terry bradshaw
about fishing
no way now look at those dogs
this looks small
what this one right here is those big
boys they look bigger than the fish you
call them out there's a large bastard
times the size of the fish that is true
and he's just giving that thing a kiss
and he says smells like his ex
yeah this fish smell like my eggs
likes to go out there and fish that's
cool i didn't know that
there he is again with that yes pass
whoa that hurts my eyes wow some people
love it
he put got his ass he's uh he says for
him it's therapeutic yeah it is just
being on the water it's a whole thing
well would only be strapped down does he
you just kind of sit down
they're on mushrooms here like probably
catch them you write catch a marlin not
be strapped in you feel me i'm not like
taking his big ass off the boat just he
just breaks
braces good sneakers all he needs is
good sneakers yeah look at him arch your
back and good damn that's so cool what
is that one large mouthfest he probably
loves he's from georgia he's like a
country there you go he grew up
fishing
that's cool there is a bit of a
technique to fishing
big time because i i trotted with my
friend who's been fishing so i didn't
catch a [ __ ] thing yeah oh drives you
crazy caught all the fish i didn't catch
anything i was doing the same thing he
was doing something like this cute ass
on that picture on top of some [ __ ]
built in l.a far left oh look at him
for one more baby mama
looking all friendly someone said fool
me three times that's funny has he got
he's got kids he's got a kid yeah he's
got two kids two kids yeah two daughters
he's got a one-year-old i think a
six-year-old someone said that sure
you're more like you pick up a daddy
mama
ellie and austin splits time he's in la
this week though
he's doing shows
yeah he's so [ __ ] funny he's good oh
go to that clip he's losing weight too
him and tony no i think it's actually
it's not that specific clip it's one
where shane's at
he's losing weight he's down a good
amount of weight yeah
he's trying he was struggling in denver
with that high altitude though i tell
you that much he can improve we were
walking to the st trying to walk to the
stadium he kept telling me to stop and
wait yeah he's funny man
oh that's him with gary clark jr [ __ ]
damn how cool is gary clark jr damn
that's amazing wow
you ever listened to gary clark bryan
yeah he's talented
i got i think he's fantastic yeah some
open for the foo fighters i listened i i
was laughing someone put timon and
pumbaa came a long way
that's what he gets he wants to roast
everybody so
his comments can be roasted
damn gary clark jr looks uh like he just
that that beard he looks
he's so talented he looks sweet he can
play that guitar he's chilling all right
jim what do you got for us zebra the
zebra that's all i had to say oh i love
zebras man listen with zebra
the zebra with the zebra you can compare
car and home coats from every major
insurance company in under five minutes
giving you all the facts you need to
make the right decision it's the fast
way to find the right coverage at the
right price all right it saves people
the zebra saves people on average of 922
a year on home and auto combined yeah
dude save time and money in minutes
compare quotes for free at the zebra.com
fighter that's the
zebra.com they focus on the details so
you don't have to oh my god
hey b you like to invest you got to
invest if you want us if you want to
save or make money for your future but
the problem is most people including
myself don't really know how to invest
or what to invest in it's too
complicated i'm too busy dude pipe down
that's right
wealthfront helps you out man if you
want to invest for long term it helps to
invest in on your terms all right maybe
you're a pro solar guy cannabis
supporter whatever it is bitcoin
whatever
you're into maybe you're a crypto nerd
whatever you are whoever you are brian
you should invest in what you believe in
and that's why
wealthfront is so freaking great all you
do is answer a few quick questions
wealthfront will build you a diverse
portfolio portfolio okay of low cost
index funds within minutes minutes so
you can build your own portfolio with
queen clean energy funds crypto trust
sure cannabis sure tech and hundreds of
other investments that we're saying yeah
and they all do they offer socially
responsible portfolios too like a mix of
funds built around human rights climate
change sustainability and diversity sure
dude wealthfront is trusted with over 27
billion bucks in assets all right get
your first 5000 manage for free for life
by going to wealthfront.com fighter
let's start building your wealth get
your first five thousand buckaroos match
for free for life go to wealthfront.com
fighter that's
w-e-a-l-t-h-f-r-o-n-t dot com fighters
start building wealth now that's
slash wealthfront.com get started today
ready
so a 18 year old tick tock star with 4
million followers on the app recently
decided to go on a police chase
on purpose
not on tick tock just for fun he decided
to take his car and drive 100 miles per
hour right passed by a cop which led to
a high speed chase
he ended up actually finding him at his
home because they knew he was gonna head
back to where he lives they arrested him
right when he got there and asked him
hey why did you do this he says because
i'm young and rich and i want to have
some fun and what happens to him now uh
he's arrested
yeah and that's about it but he also
said that yeah i know this isn't like
the best way to live but i'm just living
that lifestyle right the thing is it's
not like he's that i mean you don't get
me wrong 400 grand is a lot of cash but
it's not like you're elon musk i think
to a 18 year old that's a lot oh he's
18. yeah he's 18. he's young that's a
ton of money he just doesn't know any
better
dude just takes off next to a police
officer
[Music]
oh and runs that light yeah what was he
thinking just not thinking he said he
just wanted to have some fun i just want
to do something crazy and he thinks this
is he wasn't trying to do content or
anything no this is just cam god he is
[ __ ] out though that hell those hell
is it a hellcat yeah
yeah like a thousand it's a dodge
and they're both shirtless they're
living off of them
damn yeah
he just i believe he was arrested with
also trying to elude arrest think about
you're that bored like i guess you can
go on a high speed car 18 i'm gonna do
this yeah i thought it was for like a
content thing but it was just it was not
forgotten it was just put down
that's like that's like that thing where
young men flirt with their mortality
they just they go jump off i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna jump off this and see if
i can do that i was never that guy i
don't the only i've never been i've
always been really cautious but i
remember one time my friend goes we're
gonna go spelunking in west virginia
well you know what spelunking is no
it's where you basically crawl on your
stomach and you go in these underground
caves
and
and i went somewhere
with something else
and i was with patty jenkins and we went
and followed my friends and i was like
what if that's what i was doing why
would you want to do that now uh and now
somebody got stuck no yeah it was a
disaster that's claustrophobic you're
too big for that i'm too claustrophobic
people get stuck so this guy had to
breathe all his air out and had to push
him through and stuff i was not when i
was there but that's what i was doing
now that's that you can get lost in
there
and you're [ __ ] and you're [ __ ] so i
was i was dependent upon my friend and
then when you're doing that by the way
please understand that there are bats
right under over that's like they're
right there they're just hanging out and
you're like well there i am and we
didn't have those lights by the way we
had flashlights you didn't have social
media back then no we didn't look for
the gram the light
and the entrance to the cave was this
big like you would never see it
right i can't believe it
and then i thought i was like am i going
to get killed maybe they're going to
kill us like maybe we're just going to
die and that's what's going to happen
where do you go specifically for this
where were you at
uh we were in west virginia oh in the
woods so yeah where no hills have eyes
no [ __ ] idea my friends they have a
movie about that where these girls it's
a scary movie yeah i've seen it you know
what i'm talking about yeah the descent
the descent yeah
that's what this makes me think of i
went skydiving that was scary hard path
yeah i you know i'm not into big stuff i
just have noticed even if i wasn't i'm
not climbing mount everest i'm not doing
that [ __ ] i don't know
i got stand up i don't need you know i
don't want to die it's like who is it
who i know i did a two week oh yeah i
was talking these two women they were
they were 40. they were in such sick
shape they're at my show at liberty
township like i was like what do you
guys do they're like well i'm a crossfit
instructor but we just did a
uh it was a two-week it started with a
24-hour no it was i'm sorry it's a
52-hour endurance thing where you don't
sleep and you do this navy seal [ __ ] i
was like
oh and that gets the rocks off though
like the tough mudder has a 24-hour one
like you want to do that i'm like why
would i do that because some you're
gonna get i'm just gonna run for 24
hours stress fresh i don't sleep
why would i do that no
that's what type of person
what else you got jen
so this photograph of kim kardashian and
p davidson going on a roller coaster
holding hands is going viral
over this past weekend travis barker
kourtney kardashian kim and pete
davidson went on on like a theme park
day with a bunch of their friends and
kim and pete were seen hanging out so
now a lot of people are speculating that
they may be dating yeah but but if
you're on a ride and you grab your
friend like does it make me gay since i
grabbed my friend on splash mountain a
little bit really soft
a little bit i'm sucking like i'm
locking hands i mean if i'm like
no
one's hand on splash if i'm like this
when's that splash mountain oh it's been
a minute that drops pretty heavy if i go
like there's like a one two
yeah
that's gay yeah that's okay but but uh i
that that if i if i'm dating kim and i
see that
we're gonna have some talk
what are you doing what the [ __ ] are you
doing
what is this she was like babe we're
both scared yeah you're interlocking
your hands i'd be more casual i'd be
more locked i'd be more pissed off as
the asian girl in the front with a
shitty
she's going to go viral
your friend's like do you see you kim
kardashian post you're everywhere she's
awful
terrible picture
she's taking a [ __ ]
i was wearing diapers
thank god
i'm gonna [ __ ]
i think people are mainly assuming this
just because p davidson is known for
bagging bad [ __ ] he really is ariana
grande yeah
the girl from oh yeah wait yeah he did
he can't believe it yeah kate beckins
you know god bless he's really funny
he's probably got some swagger to him
you know yeah he's also of course you
know him from a giant day
and then he i love what he said and
especially he goes ariana grande they
planned that so that for the rest of my
life girls would be disappointed this is
a very intelligent
nice fight this is a very intelligent
person oh he's great i love pete now for
the rest of my life that's a good dude
they're like really but she said yeah
that was great that's funny
yeah the big dick energy came from him
yeah yeah
so why is she facing backlash because of
this madonna did a
photo shoot with v magazine where she
was recreating a bunch of marilyn monroe
photos and she actually recreated her
death bed does she say she looks like
alcohol
oh she went she od'd in west hollywood
all right damn
she certainly is aging fierce like she's
she's fighting she's in the fifth round
she's [ __ ] she's in the fifth round
63 oh she's like she's in the fifth
round with father time and father time's
like hi [ __ ] all right all right
all right yes she putting up a fight
that's right she's picking up a fight
she's not going gracefully no she's down
on the cards too you know
she'll do whatever she's got it's just
ridiculous there though yeah
but who's getting upset over the
memorial i mean what is my grandma upset
like who yeah
what non-boomers disrespectful too
oh they're saying it's not that that's a
big concern that's a big conspiracy too
her death
what someone said madonna will always be
an icon just like marilyn i'm here for
yeah because she was she had enough jfk
gangsters hollywood producers no there's
no reason to believe this she might have
been promiscuous yeah she and she knew a
lot so she really got with jfk oh yeah
oh yeah that's why she was singing happy
birthday to him and [ __ ] and that was
back when the mob would just they could
do that stuff man they could just it
would have the same forensic like yeah
technology like they don't know also no
cameras nothing
yeah
that one's dicey
what else you got you
um
too much shirt are you wearing
oh so you got to fire the guy
they fired that guy so there is a video
that went around the internet of a woman
getting out of the back of the amazon
truck and the amazon hook it up yeah
it's assumed that the amazon worker and
this woman were hooking up
amazon found it and actually fired the
guy watch this
relax relax oh yeah oh yeah would you
have a dog around his shoulder i mean
there was a hanging phone what is wrong
with come on you can't let a man have
some fun [ __ ] off
oh she's barefoot yeah i think she has
her phone in her she's barefoot yeah
there's something over her shoulder no
it's like a two no i think it's like
that
dress it's two people that were into
each other and they decided to be
naughty in the back of a fan i think he
has five for i guess is that frowned
upon yeah so but it's like just amazing
that's true jeff bezos can barely go on
a [ __ ] break if she gets pregnant
ostensibly sue amazon but it's like [ __ ]
you lawyers you ruined all the fun yeah
just let him can can he get a pass it
was two adults who were just trying to
be nice but what what if he was like
dude she came back there to find a
package like prove we had sex by the way
that's what i do yeah it's soothing
you're not allowed to be on the you know
yeah i would assume that people in there
yeah yeah well i put on her like dude
she jumped in the [ __ ] van jumped in
the van and then fell in like and then
my [ __ ] was all out and i don't know
what happened we were doing some light
wrestling
i like that light wrestling
man they fired him huh yeah amazing good
job too i know someone will help him out
right i'll probably start a gofundme
make more money that sucks you think
maybe they're just they're dating and
they want to do something cheap or or he
drops packages off he's a good looking
guy she knows she's not her shot she was
horny or he shot his shot one of the two
it's weird he didn't go into her place
of
where she obviously yeah he could yeah
he could have just ran up at her place
like hey got a package i'm not talking
about your [ __ ] amazon package like
it's a big dick for you this hand i know
it's having you where where
there's a moment in life where you might
be doing something and you're on your
way somewhere and a girl's there and all
of a sudden you hook up
i'm not in your van
you're amazing on the job on the job
dropping off packages you know all right
you know what i mean i mean you should
be fired i'm here maybe a maybe a
warning how many plumbers or
construction guys are there and there's
a lonely housewife i know guys yeah i
know guys who were like porno are you
watching i'm telling you
my buddy yeah i think so i believe he's
remodeling he's a good looking big
[ __ ] strong guy he's a stud kind of a
brute
and i'm telling you and i can see it uh
he he goes there he he works and
lonely housewife
it just happened birthday fourth day
fifth day and all of a sudden you're
you're banging yep
come on i believe it hey what
hold on hey bro i don't think all of
them are [ __ ] on the job not all of
them
you have a friend you have too many
friends no you i don't believe this is a
guy actually hired who did work on my
house i know him very well what do you
what are you arguing with
you i don't think you were a trainer
you were a trainer
and i said hey brennan
how many of the women and you and all of
them i know i didn't finish my sentence
but i was the ones who were married i
was like 20. i was 22 though
i was in a plumber
i wasn't a plumber with my ass when
you're when you're cracking up
plumbers
[ __ ] in here and i'm like yeah
you like
let me wash my hands i'll get in there
there's a carpenter where you're like
[Music]
i don't know what pornos you're watching
dude put this over here
she's like you smell like wood he's like
do i yeah and then you're like okay i
don't think it happens a ton okay that's
what i'm saying i think it is
good-looking i think it does yeah i just
talked too many dudes my buddy put pools
in over there it's not your buddy he's a
guy you know my buddy who he and his
buddies dig pools they
like sure enough there'd always be some
gal who'd be there and she'd have a
thing on she'd look down she'd have no
underwear on and his buddy
my one buddy my one buddy was like buddy
again he goes
yeah buddy again and there's my friends
say buddy again and he goes i'm gonna go
get a [ __ ]
and he my friend goes what he goes that
girl i'm telling you
i believe it sure enough afternoon
happens all the time happens all the
time they're called carpenters you have
so many buddies dude they're called wood
babies wood babies and when you're
working wood wood is what jesus did
you're right they were having a lot with
bellman
all the time dude
don't stop those
room service guys who are good-looking
dude all of you
can put it over there towel
apparently there's [ __ ] there why are
you acting like this doesn't happen all
the time sure it happens but you know
all right but don't be so skeptical it's
not like every plumber i've seen is
handsome is what i'm saying all right
well
they're all good they're good-looking
dudes
yeah they're probably doing all right
like you you
when you were a trainer and you did you
train people in their house never okay
you train them at the gym and then it
would just happen though you'd hook up
sometimes
uh bally's
no no how many how many were married
you didn't ask you didn't ask no i
didn't i don't know but definitely some
were probably i don't know i have no
idea yeah i guess the wedding ring was
just whatever no
they don't have it on oh
they weren't wearing it
yeah i don't know but you and your
friends did some work
i mean kind of it wasn't like a
like a frenzy no you didn't i don't know
what pornos you guys are into it
[Applause]
yeah i guess you wish what else she had
chin get me out of here
what a [ __ ] puritan
[ __ ] i think it does happen i'm just
saying it's not like a [ __ ] festival
i think it's happening right now oh yeah
around the world for sure yeah [ __ ]
every 30 seconds [ __ ] in a kitchen
yup in a closet hold on kyle bush's
apologize for using the r word he's
getting interviewed a post race
you know the r word
mentally [ __ ] yeah
you said well he drills my ass coming
out of four for no reason i mean where
was he going what was he gonna do spin
me out he was trying to do a harvick is
what he was trying to do
for what for second place to do what he
wasn't gonna transfer through with that
freaking [ __ ] man so stupid oh
it's it's the the way he's using it it's
not like he's saying he's mentally
handicapped i mean
so really was eminem dropping him now or
what i don't know i got it
you know who is our buddy who did the
podcast his son is uh has has down
syndrome and he just in and you you
remember uh john mcnally
and uh he's an actor remember remember
and he his son is has down syndrome
who's that so for him when he hears
[ __ ] it hurts his feelings so bad oh
i get it because you know and i get it
too i understand actor it's just that
sometimes we're not saying it that way
john mcnally is that his name what the
come on i should know his name he's
famous he's awesome no it's the same
like when you say like when i call
something
like if i say like we're saying
something i'll go john again i'm not
saying you're calling him actual
homosexual it's uh
it's the weight you're right and the way
you obviously i don't want to make john
feel a guy a parent of that oh he's
fantastic
i love that and he said when you said
said something how you understand
because you were talking about a friend
of yours who had it and he said can i
hug you bro like he it really meant a
lot i don't remember this yeah
and and i remember he's phenomenal he's
talking about his phone he's talking
about i don't want to make him feel bad
i don't want to be disrespectful i don't
want to
but i don't think that that nascar guy
was necessarily saying that no not at
all and i get it though if i was a
parent maybe i'd be the same way [ __ ]
yeah i'd be pissed he loves his life
yeah
how much do you love that oh my
god that's you just don't want people to
say that stuff no no he's a great
[ __ ] guy man yeah great actor
yeah yeah me too he's great he was fun
in scrubs
the best yeah right i love this
character
i get the i get the word but i also
don't think people should be canceled
for it i think it's just like uh you
know unless you're going up to little
kids no i think if someone was like
yeah it's tough right because obviously
he doesn't mean mentally disabled yeah
yeah
i don't mind people being i don't mind
they're people are voicing their their
point of view on it and it's fine maybe
it makes the world a better place i just
worry about when people get they pay a
financial price for it's like guys he
doesn't he made a mistake
but i i bet you if like
someone came up to him who has a son
with uh down syndrome was a caveman that
really affects my killing set he'd be
like oh my bad this um i won't do it
again yeah
yeah financially screwed that's why the
only reason i don't use that so i don't
want to hurt some of these feelings i i
never i never use that but way before
like it when when the f word was used
all the time right and it was acceptable
for gay people right yeah for gay people
and but i didn't i we used to use it all
the time and then my my acting teacher
told me that that to him was a word he
would hear that was a violent word
because guys who were calling him that
wanted to kill him
different meaning you didn't associate
it with once i heard that i never used
it as a comic i never use i i don't want
to make people feel bad yeah
you know once it's explained to you you
go oh i got it okay yeah
[ __ ] man corn has a song about it
whatever i kinda i'm gonna drink my bug
uh shout out to chappelle he showed me
this so the mavs are gonna lift their
kova 19 vaccine like you have to issue a
proof to get in weird because they're
lifting that up a bit of a soy boy i'm
surprised he's doing this oh really he's
a soy boy i think it's a a dallas thing
yep
wait they're going to lift yeah
but by the 15th
what would you say chen no i was just
saying that yeah for the fans to come in
and because they're under 500 cases so
that's why they're doing this they're
lifting it
you don't have to show proof you don't
have to do a test or anything you're
just going inside to the [ __ ] they
said november 5th proof of vaccination
yeah
then and as we're surprised mark owner
mark cuban responded to questions about
the
police that went further than any other
person within the state cuban told fox
it was an easy decision
for the odd vats if they don't have
cover just get a test have negative
results show it to us then you're good
to go only people that should have
problems with this are people who can't
pass code tests and want to go to a game
agree
man i just know some people that are
still super cautious and i have to be
honest with you it makes me s it really
bugs me and it makes me want to [ __ ]
not be friends with them well
i'll just they don't want to leave the
house yeah it's just like he's still
like [ __ ] he's still doing this from
the fisma man i do this anyways but yeah
i get it but it's like hey man
or they'll give you the elbow i'm like
callie mandel i just do this well he's
always been that way though
he's always been german yeah stephen
wright howie some people that way
i i don't care man if that's your thing
that's your thing yeah i i literally
don't care yeah that's how you want to i
mean whatever whatever float your boat
just don't make me just don't expect the
same out of me right correct
all right i don't know man i don't know
how legit this is but i saw this on this
instagram handle so it's though you know
the two guys island or whatever i'm an
island boy it looks like his
girlfriend's
has something like a bloody mouth and
then she's starting to hit him as well
i'll just play it for you
is he crying yeah oh look at my [ __ ]
house see oh he hit her yeah
look at my [ __ ] mouth oh he hit her
your [ __ ] father
i miss you instagram live
[Music]
i don't get it either
you must have punched her in the mouth
hi all you [ __ ] ones and my lip is
busted
i'm bleeding
you know you're stronger than me look at
your [ __ ] mouth
all right well that sounds like uh
strange just look at this though
that's something and i've been trying to
make oh my eyeliner
i imma just island boy i'ma just island
boy imma get
more minutes i don't get it right i
don't get it the whole cast is cringing
the whole thing my whole body cringes up
yeah i just go whoa and then you got
beat up by his girlfriend
right and i got and i got skeptical i
got skeptical hip eyes on that yeah
cause i mean they're they know how to
get viral so maybe posting that and
you're and it's part it's for the gram
it was a lot it was like uh she they
said that she instagrammed her i
wouldn't post that no that that made him
look terrible yeah
and then she was like you want to be
like your dad who clearly also hits
women
sounds like
i don't think his hair was getting cool
i i feel it's a little bit
that heavy dread is just just hanging
out in your head
don't have threads out of heavy because
no but don't do that yeah i feel that
that's uh i feel there's some action
yeah i kind of i'm 50 50 on it do you
know anything
no i was gonna say i don't think it's
acting i don't think it's acting yeah
yeah that makes sense
pretty hard i i feel like
it's always acting even when it's not
yeah like like i'm so skeptical these
days that's such a bad look i know
that's but nothing's gonna come from
that that's such a bad we're talking
about it and we are talking about yeah
but i mean no he's not well like legal
like yeah we're talking about hitting
his girlfriend in the mouth and her
whooping i know that's it
and you want to be and you want to be a
rapper yeah
you're not going anywhere wait so
they're rappers i thought they were just
like i don't know what they are dude
i don't think there's
there's something
there's something a little off with them
anyway oh yeah yeah why god is the
tattoos on the face and the dreads yeah
god knows what what their who what are
they who are they really
who knows they went to prison they did
yep they both went yeah drugs
for like four years they're island boys
man they went to prison for four years
oh [ __ ] some thickies yeah this is a
cool story though check this out this is
so will smith posted this do we
i've never seen this i don't think we
did i've never seen it
not many good news stories begin in such
a bad news away
here at southwood high school in
shreveport louisiana plagued with
violence over the course of three days
another fight 23 students arrested for
fighting 23 in three days but strangely
there hasn't been another incident since
perhaps in part because of this most
unusual crisis
nobody here has a degree in school
counseling
no majors in criminal justice no no your
qualifications are fair
we decided
[Laughter]
a group of about 40 southwood dads who
now hang out at the school in shifts
let's go today any negative energy that
enters the building has to run a
gauntlet of good parenting what's going
on buddy you moving fast i like that
horse i immediately felt a form of
safety we stopped fighting people
started going to class how could that
it's all it took you ever heard it
because
yes
not many people know it but yeah [ __ ]
yeah parents yeah but it's not just the
firm stares and stern warnings let's
make it to class my son it's also the
dad jokes they just make funny jokes
like oh hey your studio's untied but
it's really not the brows
you're so embarrassed by it
and it's that perfect mix of tough ones
so basically it's just a good story so
[ __ ] awesome yeah it's like do they
not have to get to work
this this no they do this [ __ ] hey you
know man you you're all right yeah
slowing down those questions
yeah they just said they do nobody did
[ __ ] oh no carpenter's not the island
boys things face and now these guys
don't have to get the word and now you
got to [ __ ] ruin it i'm just curious
they're being dads they said they do it
in shifts they didn't look like it
they're well they were working all night
there's 40 of them down 40 dads
you deserve to be canceled for that for
the dad yeah i'm just curious how the
business model works man [ __ ] no fun
i was in no fun don'ts
now it's not fun how much money did you
make of that actually they actually they
sold i'll tell you later they so get
this you're welcome and dance i think
they're shutting off sales in the 11th
or something
some of them are already being offered
for
three times what they bought them for
you're welcome we'll we'll talk about it
later i don't want to say you only paid
140 bucks
so three times so
i paid more than that per total i think
yeah yeah he bought it we have a lot of
totes i know but i thought they're like
100 bucks a toad a little more than that
we bought a lot we bought a bunch i
bought a bunch yeah but
either way we'll talk but i don't want
to say i don't want to say i'm gonna
make like well well
we still may i don't want to say that i
don't want to manipulate you like my
friend made a billion dollars off of
gorilla yeah
but i don't want to say anything
i don't want to make a thousand bucks
um we might make
a lot more than that you don't hey look
at me look at me
remember when chris was like he farted
he goes i didn't fart but the camera
couldn't see him here does he go
he's just farting
in the middle of our show
and i was like what the [ __ ] what are
you doing because brian fart i didn't
fart that was probably good
what else you got dude
oh [ __ ] man anyway great story about the
parents yeah
right i talked to this principal i go
what should we do about uh he came to my
struggle we should do about education
our education system is fine parents
suck
it's the parents
okay
this one went viral as well this little
kid 10 year olds oh this is adorable oh
holy [ __ ] watching action dude
[Music]
so cute his friend's like hell oh let me
see that [ __ ] again yeah
he's 10.
watch him one two one two holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] amazing
oh sick bro how many that was three
revolutions three double backflip huh
i think it's a trip no that was double
oh i thought it was three two what was
it no that's double double okay all
right let's watch it one more time
double back but still got the hook look
one one two two three all right double
yep
that is crazy there's a guy that did
four
all right well you got one up the 10
year old man
i can't play the music but she just
walks across their hands yeah i've done
that on i crowd surfed once like that
you crossed over yes i did at the chrome
max concert at lamoris in brooklyn i
said it look at you yeah
old school bro i know 1989 maybe
still in college i think all right man
all right
you know what i did
all right
by the way that might not be a true
story either that might be no it never
happened no no no no we've gone over
that hold on oh yeah you told me you
were saved
how did you know though did i already
admit that i didn't do that because i
thought no i know you did it
you know when a rock no rock crowd is
gonna carry brian callum like that you
don't know dude
you don't know go to your school and
monitor the halls
do that right now hey
do that there's fighting and i wasn't so
busy i would do it dude
i can see you i can see you up there
brian being a good dad and dude i'm a
great dad and i'll tell you something
yeah speaking of crowds
no i'm up first
this thursday friday no thursday friday
l.a
thursday friday that's aha we running
the 30 minutes before we shoot live in
dallas chappelle backflip lacey david
lucas this thursday friday at the ha two
shows thursday two shows friday then
shooting 30 minutes special in dallas
texas addison improv november 11th
through the 13th then [ __ ] is almost
sold out and then just announced everett
washington it's everett theater it's a
one night theater one show only november
27th i have no idea where that's at but
i'm gonna find out it looks haunted
online but we'll figure out together
everett washington november 27th but
this week la thursday friday next week
dallas texas 11 through 13.
november four and five i'm at the brea
improv let's go and then november 6th
i'll be doing the fight companion with
brendan schaub and some special guests
naples florida off the hook comedy club
november 11 12 and 13 and 14. i'm not
even taking the lord's day sunday off
and uh come see me orlando florida
improv november 19th and 20th orlando
and then and then the rest is canceled
and november 17th i'll be at tacoma
comedy club in tacoma washington then
the following night november 18th at
spokane comedy club and then december
1st san jose improv go get tickets to
fatkz.com right now uh cal bass fight
command will be back this saturday with
special guests brian myself josh
thompson one very special guest that
goes live at the thick boy youtube 7 p.m
pacific ufc 2 4 or 2
68.
alright that's it kids love you see ya